Good afternoon. I think we're going to go ahead and get started with our session
today. Thank you for joining us and learning
more about how we can leverage NCI-supported cancer epidemiology
cohorts to advance cancer prevention and control.
I just want to thank the organizers and AACR for selecting this as
one of the
NCI-sponsored sessions.
So the format of today, I'm going to give a quick welcome and
overview of what the current cancer epidemiology cohorts are
funded by NCI. And then we're going to
introduce our panel discussion, our
format, and then introduce our panelists.
And then we have about four questions that we're going to ask
specifically the panelists, and then we're going to have an open discussion.
So while you're listening to the discussion and their
responses, please start thinking of your questions.
We really want to have this as an open dialogue.
This is a mechanism for NCI to gather information from the
extramural community on really where the cancer cohort
program should go and how we really need to advance
this area.
So I'm going to go ahead and get started with giving just a quick overview
on the cancer epi cohorts.
My disclosures, I am a consultant
working with NCI as a contractor. I also have my own consulting
company, and you can see the groups that I'm working with there.
None of them are related to our conversation today.
So, I really wanted to set the stage in terms of what are cancer
epi cohorts and how do they contribute.
So this is a large observational study that is
measuring consistent exposures and
characteristics,
and prospectively following participants over time
to examine determinants of cancer risk and/or outcomes.
So these exposures can be other factors.
There's also most likely biospecimen collections
longitudinally in these studies.
We break these down, and we'll be talking about this today, into etiology or
risk cohorts, which are really following healthy
populations through cancer incidents.
And then we also have cancer survivorship cohorts, which are following
patients at diagnosis and looking at cancer outcomes.
These areas have really
expanded what we know about etiology and
survivorship outcomes, have enabled the
temporality of exposures to
cancer incidents.
So what does the cancer epi cohort
portfolio look like at NCI right now?
So in fiscal year '25, we had 56 active
cancer epidemiology cohorts that were funded.
These are all extramurally funded cohorts that I'm talking about
today, and they are managed by the Division of Cancer Control and Population
Sciences. There are cohorts that are in other divisions
within NCI, and there are also the intramural program that is
running larger cohorts as well. But we're talking about our
56 active cohorts. Eighteen of those are etiology or risk
cohorts, and
38 are survivorship cohorts. And what we've provided at the
bottom is really where's the status of these cohorts?
Where are they at in their enrollment and their follow-up?
As you can see, of the etiology cohorts,
only seven of them right now are actively enrolling, whereas
11 are in the longer-term follow-up.
And for survivorship cohorts, we have 23 of those that are
actively enrolling,
and 15 that have closed and are in follow-up.
So I'm going to give a little bit of examples of
each type of those cohorts. So the etiology cohorts, as I mentioned,
there are 18 of those. The current active cohorts
that are the seven that are enrolling, all have started in
the last about five to six years. These
are cohorts that we, as NCI, really were able to
leverage the
earlier, the long-standing cohorts, and to see where were we
missing gaps in the patient populations and
exposures, and really have focused on enrolling and starting new
cohorts that were addressing some of those other gaps.
And those were both geographically diverse populations,
demographically diverse populations, as well as having
a multigenerational population-based cohort that we have started, and
really thinking about the broad age of
participants enrolled.
These
etiology cohorts also
have the ability to measure a broad
array of omic results and exposures.
Our contemporary cohorts are
measuring environmental exposures, diet, lifestyle, and
sleep.
So we're really a vast resource for the community.
So the area of most growth more recently is the survivorship
cohorts. So,
this started being funded based off of the
infrastructure grant mechanisms in around
2012 and till
currently. So there's 38 of those funded
cohorts. You can see here that there are a
wide variety of cancer types that are being studied exclusively
in cohorts, as well as a large number that are covering multiple
different cohorts. And those covering multiple cohorts are
focusing maybe on general modalities of treatment, such as
immunotherapy, following all metastatic
cancer patients, or more recently, we had a focused
effort on looking at how patients are using
cannabis during survivorship treatments.
We have four cohorts that are funded in that
area.So
I wanted to also provide a little bit of resources for
those that are interested in collaborating with the Cancer
Epidemiology Cohort
resources. So here I've listed several
places that you can get information.
First is the Cancer Epidemiology Descriptive Cohort Database, which
is a pull together that provides some basic
information about all of the NCI-funded cohorts,
the NCI Cohort Consortium, which I'll talk a little bit more on the next slide.
But we also, in addition to just having the descriptive cohort database, we have
information on the biospecimens that are collected as part of
the cohorts.
And what's new and exciting, and hopefully you maybe were able to attend the
NCI-sponsored session this morning on
the Cancer Research Data Commons and some of the advancements that they're
making. But we recently had launched
the Population Science Data Commons, which is
a repository within the Cancer Research Data Commons,
specifically designed for population science data.
This will be a tremendous resource for
epidemiologists and population sciences to be able to have a place
to deposit their data,
and it will follow through the dbGaP controlled
access process.
And also, there is an opportunity now with NCI has
announced some administrative supplements, that there is one of those
specifically related to preparing datasets
to go into the Population Science Data Commons.
So if you're at a point where you're thinking about depositing data, that might be
a good opportunity for you.
And just wanted to highlight on the NCI Cohort Consortium, this is
something that the NCI has pulled together,
over 80 cohorts
for collaborations related to pooling of data,
and looking at how to share data and biospecimens.
And this is something that is not only NCI-funded
cohorts, but is cohorts that are really
global. And I just wanted to highlight this, that there is
opportunities within the Cohort Consortium for junior investigators
to get involved, attend the meetings, meet
the PIs and other
collaborators within the cohorts to really understand how to access
and potentially leverage these resources for their
own research. So encourage you to check out the website.
There's an annual meeting that'll be in September that is
open for people to attend.
So I just wanted to thank the group and the
Epidemiology and Genomics Research program for helping to pull this together
and really advancing the cancer epidemiology cohorts.
We have two designated program directors who are really
focused on the epidemiology cohorts and are a good
resource for anyone that would like to access these data or are interested
in proposing
grants that are leveraging the cohort group.
So I'm going to move on now to introducing our
panel,
and also how and what our goals are for
this discussion today. So
the goals here are to explore strategies for
optimizing the sustainability and utility of
resources within the cancer epidemiology cohorts.
We really want to highlight the experiences of our funded investigators
on how they've navigated leading cohorts and
where they see the future of these cohorts going.
Key discussion items that we're going to be asking them about will be data
harmonization, thoughts on returning results, and sharing
data more broadly across the community.
Some of the lessons learned on recruitment and retention for newly
funded cohorts and really how do we overcome that as we look forward.
And as well as how do you leverage cohorts to address
scientific gaps.
So I just wanted to go ahead and introduce our
panelists here.
Dr. Iona Cheng is my co-moderator of
this session. She's at the University of California in
San Diego. She's representing the Asian American
Perspective Research Cohort that has recently
been opened in the last few years, focusing on Asian
Americans. Their goal is to enroll a nationwide
population of over 20,000 Asian Americans,
to look at understanding cancer risk
among that patient population.
Dr.
Jim Doohan is
at the Mayo Clinic in Rochester. He is one of the PIs of the
Lymphoma Epidemiology and Outcomes
Cohort. This cohort is one of our survivor cohorts that's been
examining prospective clinical and epidemiology
risk factors for lymphoma outcomes.
Dr. Elena Martinez is at UC San Diego Moores Cancer
Center, and she's representing the California Teachers study that was
founded in 1995. It's a large prospective cohort of over
130,000 participants enrolled to
examine cancer risk in relation to reproductive,
hormonal, and lifestyle factors.And
Dr. Shelley Tworoger is at the Knight Cancer Center.
She's representing the Ovarian Cancer
Consortium, OC3, which is an international consortium
of cohort studies that have collaborated to study cancer risk detection and
outcomes by pooling data from over
1.5 million women across 20 different cohorts.
And finally, Wei Zheng is at the Vanderbilt University, and he
is one of the PIs of the
Southern Environmental Health Study, one of our new
SEER cohorts that has been recently funded, as well as
the PI of the Southern Community Cohort Study.
So I think we're going to move on now to our
panel discussion. So Dr. Chen, you want to...
Sure. So to start us off, our first question, and
particularly this is for Shelley and Elena.
Our question-- Oh, I'm sorry, Elena and Jim.
So from your perspective, what makes cancer epidemiology cohorts uniquely
valuable for advancing cancer prevention and control at this moment in the field?
You want me to go first?
Yes, please.
Okay. Good afternoon, everyone.
So just a show of hands, how many of you have worked in
cohort studies in any way, shape, or form?
That's what I figured.
We're preaching to the choir.
I don't think I have to tell you what the value of the cohorts are.
Erin already gave a beautiful overview of these
cohorts and the value of the cohorts, of what we can do,
questions that we can answer. But we're one of the best-kept
secrets.
I've attended some sessions here, including the
data commons session that was held a little bit earlier.
I didn't see many. There were a few epidemiologists, but I didn't see many.
Okay. So, the value, I'm not going to repeat it
because I think all of you know that.
Survivorship cohorts, etiology cohorts, the value, it's a
gold mine. Think about it. You can ask so many
questions for so many risk factors, for so many outcomes,
even though the cohort might not have started out with that question.
You can figure out how to link data, how to...
whatever it is to answer a specific question.
But the value is, I think, mostly known
among us, and it's not known outside of our group.
And I'm hoping that with the follow-up questions that are
coming, that we will get more into that.
I'm not going to spend time discussing the value, but maybe
Wei can, or who is it? No, you.
I can. Yeah.
Maybe we can go into it some more.
So yeah, why not? Yeah. Great point.
Cohorts have been the observational workhorse for 80,
100 years. But they're a well-kept secret, and part of
the issue I think we run into is a cohort study,
you can't launch it and wrap it up in five years,
right? And that's one of the... attention span of our senior leaders
sometimes is a challenge, and we'll talk about sustainability
later. What's exciting right now, well, it's always
exciting to be working in cohorts.
I think what's really happened in the last five years is the new
technologies are finally scalable at the
size of a cohort. So you can now sequence, you can start doing
proteomics, you can do metabolomics.
10 years ago, either the cost or the feasibility wasn't there.
So that opens up new questions. That's exciting.
And there's other new tools.
There's a lot more data, geospatial
data. And for those of you that missed Iona's wonderful population
science
symposium yesterday,
the amount of data available on the Googles,
and people have nothing to do with epidemiology, are collecting and putting out
there, really allows you to put your cohort, your participants into their
environment. And that's new. We weren't able to do that even 10,
20 years ago very well. So that's exciting.
So it's the new tools. And then it's
an interesting time right now to launch new cohorts.
We think we need new birth cohorts
because exposures have changed, and that will always be the case, and I
think NCI really wants to maintain a series of cohorts over
time to see what causes it, because things have changed in the
environment, particularly when people were in utero growing up, different
diets, different exposures. But then how they age with that.
That's why you don't want to stop,
"Oh, we've hit 15 years. We're done," because you miss the aging component.
So I think
that's exciting. On the survivorship side, there's always new
treatments, but
fundamentally, we're moving away from cytotoxics
into much more targeted, particularly immune-based therapies.
If you think about the pathology, we were initially really focused on the
tumor, but now we're thinking about the tumor microenvironment.
So that opens up a whole new range of questions that we can
address, again, with the new tools like digital pathology.
So AI tools are allowing us to
scale up at the level of a cohort study, which is really exciting.
So
I think it is a good time.
Getting the funding is the challenge, right?
Sure. Yeah.
I just want to add from the consortium perspective, having
all of these cohorts is a gold mine when you're
trying to understand rare cancers or tumor heterogeneity,
because we now know that the etiology of different
cancers, even from the same site of origin, are often extremely
different. And so,
from my perspective, this is one of the huge things that we have.
We have all these incredible resources, and now we can maximize it
by combining data together.
And so I
think that is also a missed opportunity and can be difficult to
get funded as well because people have a lot of concerns about
harmonization.
Which I happen to have.
That's a perfect segue into our next question, Shelley.
Shut up.
So this is for Shelley and Elena.
What have
been the biggest challenges in data harmonization across the cancer
epidemiology cohorts, and where do you see the most promising
opportunities to make progress, considering modernization of data
infrastructure and the new AI tools that we've been hearing a lot about
this meeting?
Yeah. So,
I realized at this meeting that our consortium started
15 years ago, we got our first grant.
And
10 years of that, I swear to you, is harmonizing
variables across the studies.
And it's an extremely laborious and manual
process because you have to evaluate how each question was asked, what the answers
were. You have to decide how you can harmonize across
all of these different studies. There's a lot of
technical coding that goes along with actually
coding all of those things. And I will say the
computing infrastructure has improved.
There's things like the OPAL platform from Maelstrom that allows you
to have code books and harmonization all documented
in a database that's searchable. But I really
think if we're going to leverage the power of
consortia, we absolutely have to move to more
automated approaches to harmonization.
And there are a number of opportunities that exist out there
that people are working on. There's folks in NCI
Intramural who are developing AI-based tools,
not only to pull in the data dictionaries from these
cohorts, but sort them by using large language models,
sort them by topics,
and then evaluating how the questions and responses are
asked to create harmonization code.
The thing is, there's lots of things that have been built, but we haven't
validated how well these work. And I do think it'll probably
never be fully automated. It'll probably be semi-automated.
There's also other AI tools that we've been exploring,
such as things like knowledge graphs.
And please don't ask me later to explain a knowledge graph because I'm still
learning it. But our AI colleagues are talking about how we
don't necessarily have to even directly harmonize the data.
We can use large language models and other types of
AI to combine information that is
semantically similar and then use that information to
look for correlations so that we can hone in on the areas
that might be the most fruitful for us to look at.
And the great part about that is that you can just push all the data in all at
once. You don't have to pick which variables you want to spend
a year harmonizing. So I think to me, some of those
opportunities in the AI space are things that we really need to do.
Finally, I think we need to be sharing more with
each other. So an initiative we've been talking about with
NCI is how do we share back our harmonization code
with the cohorts or with other consortia that might want to harmonize in
the same way so that it'll be easier in the future
for other people? Because what's happening is the Liver Cancer Consortium and the
Ovarian Cancer Consortium and the Breast Cancer Consortium, they're all
harmonizing the same variables. So we're just reduplicating work,
and I think that's another area where we need to share with each other and figure
out ways to do that.
I think you've covered just about all my notes that I had here.
Okay.
No, that's great. I'm going to reiterate that.
But I think we also have to think, I learned in the
Data Commons
session,
data harmonization and data curation, right?
In epi, I think the
variables that we've worked on for the most part, we've
done that to death, right? BMI, smoking, all of that.
It's almost like we don't need to really worry about those.
Those are low priority. What are the priority variables that
we need to focus on? The geospatial, the environmental
factors, all of those that we haven't worked on, and how is that
going to take place? I agree with Shelley.
The AI tools that I learned about in the earlier session,
amazing. And they're
even inviting users to go in and play with the
tools and play with the data. I don't think we're there for population
sciences data, but all the other data, they're making that
available so that I can sign up as a user and test it
out and give feedback. This isn't working, this didn't work, what
have you, but it's a community that we're bringing together to learn
from each other.
Sharing of code, I think, is really, really important.
And the CTS,
Jim Lacy and his team, if they develop
something, they make the code available for free.
You can have the code. They'll publish it.
We'll publish it on the CTS website.
I don't think we're doing enough of that.
I think sometimes we keep siloing
ourselves and reinventing the wheel, even though we're working in the
somewhat equal space. So-and-so is doing it this way,
so-and-so is doing it this way, so-and-so is doing it that way.
But yet we don't really know what the differences are all the
time of how we're generating this data.
So sharing,
learning from the data scientists, really.
They really don't have any kind of like, "Put the data
out there. Tell me if it works. If it doesn't work, I'll improve it
and work on it," and a continuous sharing of data
and code.
Thank you.
So the next question is for Wei and Jim.
How are cohorts currently thinking about the return of results to participants,
and what ethical or practical considerations remain unresolved?
Okay. I wonder how many of you have shared data with your study
participants, return data, just raise your hand.
So there are some, right? So just for
everybody's knowledge, historically, we don't share data
results with participants.
Actually, in our consent form, we actually specifically said no
return testing results, right? I think the primary
concern is these are research data, not for
clinical care,
and are
not clinically actionable, and also the
result not validated, so may be
misinterpreted, and it even can cause harm.
And then another reason we didn't do that in the past
is that a lot of study just don't have
the enough resource to support the
returning results and then provide the
downstream action like confirmative testing.
So I think now the cohort now have moved
from no return data,
to a model that conditional return the data.
And so, because just the ethical
obligation for those actionable data we need to
return to study participants. But it's
not even just implemented in study.
Some study like UK Biobank,
in their consent form, it's no return.
But if they have some incidental findings, like
from their image, they did have the protocol to return
data and then talk to their clinicians.
We, myself, we haven't done that in our study, but we certain
think about it.
As I think Aaron mentioned earlier that
the new cohort in cancer environmental health cohort
study, so there are several cohort study.
We are building a study now.
The
1,000-family study led by University of
Minnesota,
they actually return radon testing data
to study participants because in Minnesota, Jim will
know, the background radon level is pretty high, right?
So it end up actually 65% of the family need to
do retesting. So I think that is quite
significant, not just a benefit to study participants.
I think in general, so the field has moved
to return some data, but you always need to think about when the
results are actionable,
when they're clinically relevant, health relevant,
and also need to work with your IRB to think about the
protocols and how to return the data.
So I think that's what I want to say.
I think something, Jim, you want to add?
Yeah, it's a
long career and a lot of studies, and only two of them ever returned results.
One was way back, an old case control study where we returned nitrate levels,
and we measured it in the water home tap sample.
That was in
2002.
It was a long time ago.
But most of our studies, we don't. We've not really been encouraged.
In a separate, in a biobank we developed out of Mayo Clinic
patients, 50,000, we have been returning genetic
results. And it's a big process.
We had a community advisory board. They recommended we do it.
But then how do you do it?
So we focused on the ACMG 70...
Well, it started at 72, now it's 78. That's one of the issues, right?
That you keep finding more and more, and when do you stop?
We first realized you had to
get the results back. We return them under research, so we're not going
to call this clinical at all. But there's a whole
precedent for returning research results, incidental findings on
images. The lung cancer trials, they'd find something, they'd
put it out there.
We always treat genetics extra special,
for better or worse.
And what we found is the first thing you have to do is just
go to the record and make sure they don't already know it.
Mm-hmm.
I'd say 30% to 40% already knew they were a BRCA1 carrying
actionable variant. And
then you have to... Okay, then you get through that loop, then you have to
contact them and let them decide whether they want
the result.
And we actually had a long discussion, interesting, with our community advisory
board about... They said, "Well, why are you only returning
actionable results? What if I just want to know?" Somebody said, "I want to
pray on it." And it's like, I never thought of that.
We still kept it in the clinical actionable,
but not returned in their medical... First they have to decide, do I want to know?
And then we actually had chatbots to help them walk through that because
suddenly we've got thousands of people in a short time to interact
with. Then they could get to a genetic counselor.
I don't know if your institution, but genetic counselors are hard to find.
There's not many of them. And then, so they can make the
decision then if they wanted to do it, we replicated the
result, still as a research result on their original blood
sample.
And then based on that, recommended they should go
and hook them up with a clinical
parallel result. So it's been a long process.
There's been some people thatProbably.
I don't know if it saved their life, but a few of them
had been on diagnostic odysseys their whole life.
They got the result back and went in, and their whole family got worked up.
And they're like--
It was life-changing for them. Those are anecdotes, and epidemiologists, we're
very careful about anecdotes.
So it's a tough call. We decided to put it all under research
because
as now that we can sequence the whole genome, this is only going to become a bigger
issue. And so we need to learn how people can engage and want to find out
results and move on with them. But it's almost a whole research
thing in and of itself-
Mm. Yeah
... beyond just the cohorts doing their work.
And I don't know that we have the resources to do this
globally. So no easy
answers on that one.
Exactly.
Ping.
So if you're interested in this area,
you can also look at See All Of Us, how they return the
data.
Mm.
They're actually doing a very good job.
So they return
all the pathogenic variants identified on those
cancer genes. There's a panel, and they did a whole genome sequencing.
And then they provide confirmative testing free of
charge, and also provide genetic counseling, just like James
said.
So I think people benefit from this.
Oh, they also return pharmacogenomic data.
Some of these actionable interaction with drugs, so it's
good for them to know.
That's great. Sounds like a lot more work needs to happen to be able to do
this and meet the needs of the community as well as what we can fund in
the extramural cohorts. So thank you.
I want to move on now to thinking about recruitment and retention.
We do have some new cohorts that are doing recruitment using
novel ways, and I really want to hear from Wei and
Iona on lessons learned that have emerged
during recruitment and retention of our newly funded cohorts that are
particularly relevant for thinking about the future cohorts that we
might need to be planned.
Go ahead.
So the biggest lesson we learned is that response rate is much lower
than it used to be . So we need to work really hard
to really improve the response rate.
There's certain many things we can do,
but I just want to highlight two things.
I think Iona can add some other things.
One is the building trust.
So
some of you know that
about 20 years ago, we started a study called Southern Community
Cohort Study. The study led initially by Bill
Broad.
So the major aim for that study is to
recruit African American and low-income American.
So those people are really
underrepresented in large cohort study.
So to do that,
Bill Broad developed a novel strategy
to recruit people from the community health center.
So as you know these centers provide affordable care,
even just free care
to underserved population.
As this result, we actually in partnership with 71
community health center across 12 southern states
we recruited about 70,000 study
participants through this
network. So this lesson is still
applicable to our new study we call Southern Environmental Health
Study. We started in
2021 to recruit
35,000 people, and we particularly want to recruit
low-income population because they tend to live
in no economic resource area and
also
environment polluted area. So we use this approach
so the community health center not only help us recruit
participants, but also help us refine study
protocols and the questionnaire.
So I think one thing we learn from that is build trust.
Another one is using the new
technologies.
So in the past, we typically used a paper form of consent,
like paper questionnaire, those kind of things, doing phone
interview,
in-person interview.
But that technology has really evolved for
many years now. So for the new study, we
call SEHS, we develop IT system.
So we do this digital recruitment and also e-consent.
Probably not new for
many of you, but that work well, particularly when you have
a limited resource.
Participants can complete the online survey, but
certainly there are some problem that we probably, if I have time, so we can
go there.
And also we use social
medias like Facebook, Instagram to
reach a large area.
This is particularly important because the environment health study, we
want to cover a large area of the population.
So we end up actually recruit people from the 17 southern
state and also DC area. So I think that's
one thing, technology.
Another thing we are doing is using wearable device.
We use the silicon wristband
to collect the external exposure sample
that we can analyze about 500 chemical signatures.
So a lot of participants are fascinated with this
technology, so they are willing to participate.
It's a high-tech study,
kind of attractive. And also in
the past, when you want to do these
air pollution
collection, you use pump. This is pretty heavy.
The wristband is small, so I think the burden to
participant is low, so they are more willing to do that.
Certainly, some people concerned about when the drug they use can
get into the wristband we analyze, so that's another story.
But a lot of things we can do. AI, maybe.
We haven't done that yet, but I think something certainly we can explore.
So we've been fortunate through a new opportunity from NCI to build
what was referred to as the next generation cohort.
And this is a building phase of the cohort, and so we are recruiting
20,000 Asian Americans nationally across the US.
And with that, there's a big emphasis on community engagement.
And also recognizing as this, we're using modern
technologies similar to digital and online recruitment, but
there is a really important emphasis in terms of working with our community
partners. And so that element of building trust.
We have five sites who have known relationships with
specific Asian American community groups, and we know that we need to
meet
our community members with what they are most comfortable with in terms of
participating. So for just an example, I think I saw
Jane in the room from Cedars.
They are helping to recruit Korean Americans into our cohort.
They have very strong relationships with the Korean
churches, and they are using their navigators there.
They'll hold
informational session on cancer screening, which people are interested in.
It builds trust and engagements with leaders in their
community. And then we talk to them about Aspire.
So, this is an effective approach, but of course, that takes time,
right? Our primary method is digital and online because we really want to be able
to be efficient, right, in terms of recruiting of individuals,
processing. But we know that we need to be flexible and have different
modalities
to be able to reach all the community members to represent the Asian
community. So that's one lesson that we've learned.
Another lesson that we've learned is that I think all of us are faced with the
challenges of acquiring identifiers, right?
And we know that we need identifiers such as addresses and phone numbers because
ultimately we need to do linkages, right? So how do we frame this question?
Because we're all very protective, and we know the importance of having these
down the road, right? And so that's one of the things that we're kind of grappling
with in terms of really being able to get the kind of identifying information we
need.
And then I think the third thing I wanted to highlight, and I'm not sure how many
others in the room have had experience with, was that our community advisory board
was very clear that we need to offer incentives, right?
And so with offering incentives, this was a whole other field that
I didn't realize was occurring, and this actually was highlighted
in a "Nature News" article, is that there are AI
chatbots and things called click farms where there
are
people pretending to be participants. So they're fraudulent actors, right?
And so with that, you need to develop a system to
address and identify them. And we've done a lot of
work in trying to sort this out and in talking to other
cohort leaders who are also developing cohort.
I think this is a common problem, but we haven't collectively...
I think that sharing of information, I think, to try to address this collectively
as a field is really important. So just to highlight some of the measures that
we've been using. So if we get an address, we geocode it, and then we
categorize it. Is it really precise? Is it possibly fraudulent?
Is it unlikely, or is it just missing?
We look for pattern recognitions, right?
So is there something funky in the email domains?
Is there something strange in the patterns?
Or their names, they report two first names or just something
strange. So we go through that.
We also look at positive aspects, right?
We are offering ultimately our survey in seven,
I think seven Asian languages. And so are they using a
non-English survey? Do they report that they were recruited
by a community resource?
Are their names consistent with their target ethnicity?
So we have a whole host of measures to try to identify
this, but this is definitely something that's happening across the field,
that I think there needs to be a lot of additional conversations, and of
course, this takes time and resources, right?
We also have to make some phone calls.
So these are a lot of some of the challenges that we're working through.
Anyone else want to comment on that?
Well, it's been interesting.
I've been in the field maybe too long.
Things have cycled back in our retention.
We're back to using paper
because we get better response rates.
Well, you have to have multimodal, right?
What the problem with Qualtrics? Well, it shows up, and it says, "Click here." And
we're all now embedded, "Don't click here," right?
You're going to get in trouble. And if you think about it, I've reflected on my
own. My own mailbox is not very full anymore,
but my email inbox and my
text inbox is filled with crap.
And so it's noise, right? So people just ignore it.
So I've never thought we'd see it circle all the way
back, but now we're going back to paper. And it's not an age thing.
There are old people that love digital,
and there are young people that are huge privacy, and they said, "Only
contact me by paper." So
the only challenge is now you have to
maintain multimodality, which is a lot of work.
Right. Yeah, yeah.
I will say a not NCI funded cohort at
the Knight Cancer Institute is really embedded in the
community outreach and engagement space.
And so a lot of what they do to give incentive isn't
financial, but actually return of
results in the sense of how do you compare to the population or what
is going on in your community, and it's really trying
to focus based on what the community is saying that they're interested in
learning about or interested in hearing about.
And then they actually are giving input on scientific areas that
they think should be studied within the state of Oregon.
So I think there's
... creative ways to give incentives that maybe will get around the
bots. They also were giving free genetic testing
for a long time, and that really helped with
recruitment.
Can I add two things?
Yes.
About paper survey, actually, I agree with Jane.
In our study, when we used the digital online
survey, and we noticed about 20% people never finished it.
And later we just realized that we need to offer this paper
form, actually mail the paper and then they filled out and then mail back.
And then actually they help tremendously. So I think that's one thing.
Another thing is about digital recruitment.
So when you start the algorithm, so you aim,
say, even male, females, but then the algorithm
learn the woman responds more to a
survey, and then they just more target woman population.
Uh-huh.
So you need to do this adjustment, just when you do digital
recruitment. So theoretically, we need to put more
weight for males, so they tend to not to respond
survey as women.
Interesting.
Yeah.
That's great. Well, that is really-
So it's working
... yeah, lots of challenges, and it is all coming full circle.
So we have 15 minutes left, so I'm going to go ahead and open it up to the
floor. If you have a question for our panelists or
myself, please come up to one of the two mics, and
hopefully we'll have a good discussion.
Hi, everyone.
I think that turned it on.
Try it again.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Thank you for this interesting and helpful talk.
So I had a hypothesis I wanted addressed.
This was about a month ago, and I spent a long time looking through the cancer
cohorts that I could find. And by the way, shout out to the California Teacher
Study for putting all of your questionnaires online. Thank you for doing that.
But a lot of the other cohorts don't have it online, and I'm wondering if there is
a more unified way that NCI could have
detailed information on which cohorts asked which
questions
and is there a more efficient way that people can find out what's
available?
Yeah, good question. I think over time, NCI's really
tried hard to gather as much information as possible and to put
those resources on their website.
The database that I mentioned is one of those resources.
Where I see that we may be moving towards is the population science data
commons that I alluded to and Elena talked about.
As that matures, I'm hopeful that more information,
details about the cohort as well as what they have asked
and a lot of their survey information will be there as a resource
for people to leverage. And I also think that that's an
opportunity to link code and harmonization code as well and
have multiple levels of data. So that may be an option, but I think
it's really challenging given the number of questionnaires
that are asked, the longitudinal follow-up to really have a really
comprehensive database.
I don't know if anyone else has thoughts on that or...
That's what that cancer epidemiology descriptive database is supposed to be,
but it
just is very difficult because the cohorts that have many
questionnaires over time, and they ask different questions in different cycles.
And so it really does come down to looking, and this
is where I think one thing actually that we're trying to do with AI is
be able to use these copies of scans of
Scantron forms to have the AI actually take
those forms and pull in all the questions and the
responses so that we can make it more easily
available to people. But so I do think we're going to have to use some different
tools to be able to do that.
I will say that it requires resources and funding and
additional funding because the California Teacher Study,
one of the iterations of the grant was to modernize
the CTS. It was about modernization, so there were
funds available to do that, and so if
you go on the CTS website,
it's pretty user-friendly, all things considered.
You can find just about everything.
You know exactly when things were collected, and everything is done
in real time. But it took a specific grant with the
PI saying, "This is what's needed, and this is what we need to
do to be able to happen."
The other cohorts did not have the resources or
do not have the resources to do that.
And so I think resources are very important for
getting there.
Yeah. Next question.
Hi. Janine Figueroa from NCI. So I've had
the, I guess, privilege to have worked both in the UK
and the US, and huge differences, right?
Mm-hmm.
You talked about the UK Biobank. There's an infrastructure to collect health
records over the life course, and there's still challenges even
when you're in a universal healthcare system.
And obviously, I think that leads me to big data.
Us epidemiologists who have been looking at data for some time are
getting, I don't know, I feel like we have to exert our
importance a bit more-
Mm-hmm
... and not get eclipsed by big data and EHR
records. I think we've always cared about those things, but they don't tell the
whole story.
Mm-hmm.
And our fragmented system in the United States is never going to give us the
complete picture. That's why we absolutely need well
designed cohorts for the future. And so I'm wondering, how do you
see us actually making sure we keep that, I guess, that
important vision, our importance alive?
Because I think everybody's talking about, "Well, we're going to use EHR
and it's going to solve all our problems." And I'm sure there's efficiencies there
but
They're not going to tell us the whole story.
Sure. I can get this started. I'm looking at the
younger people. Seriously, I'm looking at the younger people.
I've met, in this meeting and the ASPO meeting,
these bright young people that think differently
than I do. I'll point the finger to me.
They're coming up with such innovative answers
to make things work and modernize.
And yes, looking at the UK Biobank,
my colleague, Ludmil Alexandrov, who is just an
amazing data scientist,
the way he was able to get the answer, or one of the
answers, or address a hypothesis to early-onset colorectal
cancer, is studies that didn't involve the US.
And I asked Ludmil, "Why didn't you include
any studies?" "I can't afford it.
I
had to go to countries where people were willing
to collect data,
biospecimens, and share the data willingly.
If I had to do this in the US, I wouldn't be able to afford it."
He was able to get all these nature papers doing it,
but sadly saying, "I can't do it in the US.
I wish I could have."
Mm.
And that's sad, right?
But I think those genius minds, the younger
people, are going to help us get there.
That's my take.
I can add a couple things. I think that we have a unique
opportunity to address the
emerging questions of today. So for example,
we're thinking about how we can leverage some of the
younger, newer birth cohorts to come
together in a pooled consortium way to look at early onset
cancers. Because even though the incidence is increasing,
they're still relatively rare.
A lot of the even older cohorts are doing linkage to
geospatial factors. Many of the cohorts have blood and can do new
assays. So even though the cohorts are old in our minds, they
still can be used to answer new and important questions.
And yes, we still have to have new cohorts because,
I'll never be able to study hormonal IUDs and
ovarian cancer in the older cohorts.
But we still have a lot of things that can be done
to do it. And I think NCI has initiatives that are
focused on early cancers, rare cancers, environmental
exposures, and those are places where we can make an impact quickly.
Wang?
Can I answer you? So, Janine, you mentioned about UKB
and then our cohort studies.
The setup's different, right? So that's really preventing us
the sharing as extensive as UKB.
So like consent form, right? It's a different consent form.
So I think that's one thing. But new cohort study now
have more explicitly about sharing.
So for example, our new study, the consent form is
seven pages. When I look at back, our SCCS consent form,
two pages. And so there's a difference, in explaining a lot of details.
But certainly make recruitment more difficult,
because people read that seven pages consent form, all the legal
things, they don't understand.
I think that's one thing, another is the resource.
So UKB spent millions of pounds,
just the data center, and then suddenly they get some of money back
and then for data sharing. But I don't think we have the system
here to support that kind of data sharing.
I think I'm just going to add one little point is that, I think there are a lot of
opportunities and I've done EHR-based studies.
And we know the strengths of what kind of research questions they ask.
But I think we are all epidemiologists. We know about bias.
We know about confounding. We know about the questions to ask really
robust and rigorous epidemiological answers with
observational data that was designed to answer those type of questions.
So there's strengths and weaknesses to each of those types of systems.
Mm.
Well, I'm going to poison. I'm old, but I still think differently, and
I'm not an epidemiologist. So,
I have two urgent questions, but I'm going to limit it to one.
So when you guys do the studies and the patients get cancer, and then
they pass away,
no study I know of, and even our hospital doesn't do it,
records the cause of death. And sometimes when the patients
get involved at Stage 1, it gets carried over to Stage 1.
It doesn't mean that he died of Stage 4.
Are you guys not supposed to figure out what
causes the cause of death? And I just can't find these studies.
And you do all these studies before they die, but I want to keep the patient alive,
so I need to know what's the cause of death. Is that not a stupid question?
Yeah, a lot of studies actually get death certificates and medical
records related to the death to abstract cause
of death.
Have you looked at these records? Are they really writing down cardiovascular,
et cetera? Or do they say, "Oh, he passed away"?
Well, I think once people get much older, like
in their mid-80s or older, oftentimes they don't know the cause of death.
But, I think we do a pretty good job of getting cause of death.
Yeah, there's usually a primary...
The physician on record will label a primary cause of death,
secondary cause of death. But of course, as we understand, there can be errors in
that, right? Given comorbidities and things happening at that time.
Yeah, we actually review our causes of death because it does allow you to move from
Kaplan-Meier into really cumulative incidence and competing risk models, but
that's a lot of work.
It's expensive.
Yeah.
Hi, my name is Naomi Sakura. I'm coming from Tokyo, Japan,
and I'm a patient advocate. So I want to
know,
do you always collaborate with some of the basic
researchers or policy makers? Because in Japan,
unfortunately, those results do not
contribute back to the society of our
activities. So I really want to know,
do your cohort results
always
collaborate with the researcher or policy maker or something policy?
So, like collaborating with basic scientists?
With basic scientists.
Yeah. I think a lot of us collaborate with basic science because
we're really trying to understand the mechanisms of
how
the exposures that we're looking at-
Mm
... are associated with risk. So for example, I have
two grants right now where we're looking at
depression and social isolation in relation to ovarian cancer
onset and how the immune system responds to the tumor,
and we're looking at it in both cohort studies, prospective cohort
studies, like are discussed today, and also in animal models.
So I think a lot of us do correlate, and
I think actually it's an untapped opportunity for more of us to be working
in parallel with basic scientists on these important questions.
But sometimes it can be hard to identify
the right connection or the right collaboration.
It can be challenging sometimes.
Oh.
I will say that at my institution, UC San Diego, basic
scientists are like, we can't even compete with them because they're so good.
That's reality. I'm sure it is the same at your
institution. They come to us with questions, and the cohorts don't
exist.
Yeah.
Right?
So they have questions about this
factor, this mechanism, and this population.
We don't
have cohorts. We don't have enough cohorts to address those
questions, right? So the early answer right now is like-
Or the right samples
... where are the biospecimens? Where are the right samples?
We have all these really interested basic scientists
at my institution, but we just don't have the resources for them to
get involved. So my plea is for more cohorts
to help more with these collaborations.
So thank you for your question.
Wow.
I think the easiest way to do that is
some basic science laboratory develops some biomarkers, and then we
apply it to our cohort study to validate that in humans.
And we have done quite a lot over the past, say, 10 or 15 years.
So one example is the
prostate grading E2 metabolites and then developed by a basic
scientist
at Vanderbilt. And we used that, and then
actually now, this biomarker actually
used for intervention trial as an intermediate biomarker.
So I think that's an interesting story from basic science
to translation.
So thank you very much. When I go back to Japan, I share today
the presentation with some of the young scientists.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Scarlett?
Yeah. We'll do one more last question.
All right. Okay.
Scarlett Gomez, UCSF, and with Iona, I'm one of the MPIs of the ASPIRE
cohort. I have two questions. My first question of, if anyone's
interested in learning about the ASPIRE cohort- ... I have flyers.
Okay, sorry. I had to. Iona asked me to do it.
I have a second actual question, and this is for Wei or for anyone on the panel.
So Wei, you mentioned that you guys are doing the silicon wristbands, and you're
asking for
exposure to environmental contaminants as well as collecting
geospatial data, I'm guessing, that captures objective
measures of the environment. Are you returning that to the
participants? Because
just like with genetic data, we have to think about offering them genetic
counseling. But this is a whole other type of
potential. Do you advise them about the levels in their
environment-
Yeah
... that they may be exposed to, mitigation measures?
I'd be really interested to hear that-
Yeah
... and others as well who may have an experience.
Yeah. We
have a lot of discussion about this, the wristband data.
So I know the
1,000
Family Study in Minnesota returned
PFAS data.
Mm.
So we're wondering,
this data, how useful is this data?
And the wristband can identify 500 different kind of
compounds there. So we had a lot of discussion at what
kind of data to return, and when is that useful for them.
And maybe some are useful. And actually, there's a
institute called Silent Spring.
Silent Spring, they developed
a pipeline called DERBI, and we look at this stuff, and then
actually can have these return make our life easier.
So we're thinking about it. So we haven't decided what to return, but I think
that's a good question, yeah. Mm-hmm.
So the Oregon-based cohort I was mentioning called Healthy Oregon Project,
they are doing wristbands. They've done a pilot, and then
they're trying to get money to do a larger same wristbands.
And so they actually returned results, but again, not
the individual person's results, but the
distribution across the state.
So people can sort of see how where they live
looks. And they only picked ones where there was something kind of known
about it. So they did do some selective reporting, but
just not individual level results, more sort of
population-based results, and then people could look at their
area. And then there were resources if there were things like
actionable things that could be
addressed, like radon, then they were given resources for them to look
into.
Great. Well, I know we're at time. So I just want to thank our panelists
for really taking the time and helping us think
through this and providing this information to NCI.
I pulled back up our slide with our two contacts.
If you had other questions or have other feedback for NCI related to
cohorts, please reach out to them, reach out to me.
We're happy to hear your thoughts and really appreciate the
feedback and all of the questions today. So thank you.
Nice job.
Yeah.